hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds and i'm sat here in darcy's house
darcy is the newest financially free
student on our academy and darcy i just
want to say firstly thanks for having me
around your house you're very welcome so
you are 20 years old yeah you joined the
academy when you were 19. yeah you quit
your job
too fast yeah tell me about tell me
about that like what were you doing when
we met what was the so i was doing a
degree apprenticeship at an investment
bank you know your typical good career
all of that you know traditional route
um but i always knew that when my degree
finished i wanted to go into property
because i've been watching youtube for
years
and then during the pandemic just made
me realize why wait
like i know i can do it
why wait like why not just do it now
so
i did a couple of your free courses
and then i paid for the advanced
training i did
as soon as i started the advanced
training i literally loved it like i
would actually not work when i was meant
to be working and just do your training
and this was like join kind of
pandemic kind of time yeah when you join
the academy you did the the online
version yeah um so you're going and of
course we were on zoom and chatting and
doing stuff but it was kind of online
and at the time you were working
full-time would you say you're studying
for uni as well yes so it's just so many
hours and i remember on the financial
freedom intensive course when we were
chatting in a group but we were chatting
and you said i want to quit my job i'm
tired of it and i was like well before
you do that right you need to do this do
this and you completely ignored me
and you just went and quit everything i
know yeah i just i'm very confident in
myself
and i knew that if i quit then i would
have no other choice but to be
successful because you know like i had a
lot on the line then i wasn't
comfortable i didn't still have that
paycheck every month so i was like well
if i eradicate the paycheck
then it puts pressure on me
and i know that if i have the training i
can do it and if i don't it's my own
fault and i wouldn't advise that because
if you'd have failed you'd then be in
debt because of the training you'd be
jobless i would be satan yeah i don't
really believe in failure though because
i think
in life you are taught something and
then you put it into action
so if you either don't do the training
then you won't be successful and if you
do do the training you can be but it's
on you like it's on yourself like i
never ever put anything on you or your
training it was up to me to be
successful like if you can do it if any
other human being could do it i can it's
just a matter of
picking up the awkward phone calls and
making them but there's from my
perspective though there's still a way
of responsibility on me like you were a
teenager at the time you were 19. having
a 19 year old
go on and and i don't even know how you
how did you afford how did you afford
the training because it was i'd saved up
from my degree i was getting paid from
the degree apprenticeship like a very
good wage for my age so and obviously
room in lockdown i was still living at
home i didn't have really any cost so i
just saved as much as i could and then
just paid for the training still had a
bit of savings left over and what was
your salary
in your job it was 22 000 a year which
is great for a teenager yeah i mean 22
grand is is is fabulous so okay so you
went through the train then you quit
your job you joined me live on the
service accommodation intensive bang
what happened on that program so that
was the best thing ever because we could
go in person and i do believe that
environment is everything especially if
you're new
because you can then meet people that
have done it you see success kind of in
the flesh
so you believe it a lot more
and so we made the phone calls to the
agents and i managed to get a viewing
for an apartment in portsmouth which i
was like brilliant and this was actually
on the program yeah this was on the
training you know after we've been
taught everything been given the scripts
of what to say
so yeah i made that phone call and then
that phone call i didn't know it but
would later turn into my first deal
incredible so talk me through then your
first deal is in portsmouth
what did you say to the agent how did
you actually get it 19 years old no job
at the time because you just quit right
yes so you didn't have references you
couldn't say oh i've got a normally when
you rent somewhere they'll say to you
can you afford it yeah you didn't have a
job you didn't really you had a tiddly
bit left in savings yeah
how did that happen
so i managed to negotiate the rent down
from what it was
um and i basically just
you know used all the advantages of
being a company let it's a company you
know it's guaranteed rent you know it's
you know you've got a lot more on the
line than your company someone can hold
you accountable which for the landlord
is very appealing because obviously with
the tenant it's very very hard to hold
them responsible and get any money back
but it's different with the company and
i just explained all those benefits and
they had dealt with company likes before
which really helped because they knew
what it was
they did ask for a guarantor and
thankfully my dad was one for me so i
will be grateful for him for that um so
i did need a guarantor
but yeah i just sold all the advantages
really yeah so basically you get a
viewing you told the agent up front this
is a company let you went round you
pitched them on the concept of how this
would work what it would look like
because you'd quit your job you had zero
income you needed to get guarantor if
your dad hadn't done it you've got
somebody else doing no doubt oh yeah
like
not having it wasn't an option like i
knew if i needed it i'd find it
somewhere yeah yeah so so rent wise and
you by the way darcy you are
a very smooth negotiator
like even this sofa that was sat on in
one of your service service houses
you know this was a two thousand pound
sofa and you negotiated it at how much
eight hundred eight hundred from two
grand i mean that's ridiculous you're a
very good negotiator yeah so and i think
that's a natural ability as well i mean
yeah i know you've learned a lot about
property and service accommodation but
you're naturally a confident yeah good
negotiator so rent wise what did you
manage to get the rent for on that first
apartment so it was at
1150 pounds and i managed to get it for
1075
which doesn't seem like a big difference
but you think that was lit that is now
my wi-fi and electric bill
done so it actually has saved me
a bit every single month and the market
is booming so the tenants are queuing up
so okay okay so not bad and profit wise
how much are you renting that out for
and what kind of profit are you making
from that first apartment that you got
so the profit on average is about
nearly a thousand pounds a month which
i'm really happy for because you know
it's a cheap rent it's in a great
location i
to be fair would be making more but i
pay for private parking for my guests
because i know how much of a nightmare
parking can be in a city center
and it is expensive i have to pay 130
pounds a month for it but it's worth it
because then i don't get guests saying
oh i had the hassle of trying to park
right and it keeps your reviews it keeps
your reputation yeah but you're making a
profit of about 950 pounds yes that was
on your first deal and you got that on
the program yes i mean high five
what did that do i mean a lot of people
say your first deal is the hardest what
did that do for your confidence for your
belief
um
what happened when you got that first
deal in you it did so much for me
confidence wise i mean it solidified
what i had learned and what i knew i
could do
and it also
just gave me that boost of the first is
the hardest and once you've got one you
then have something to leverage when
you're going to get number two because
you could say well i can give you a line
of reference or well i got this one
through another agent yeah or this is
how they did it
you just have a lot more to play with
but a good skill i learnt with even if
you don't have one
leverage other people's as long as you
have their permission
and say you know oh well my business
acquaintance has five
yes you know so you've always got
something to play with it's all about
knowing the right people yeah absolutely
and knowing what to say how to leverage
not just leverage money but also
leverage people's credibility but in the
right way where you're being ethical
yeah um when you quit your job
what did everybody think
they thought i was crazy
um
the only person that truly supported me
was ben um because he knew that if i
want to do something i was going to do
it and ben is your boyfriend yes yeah
he's my partner for quite a while now
and uh my family as much as they love
and support me they didn't understand it
because they'd you know i'm not from a
rich background and they saw this as a
really secure job for me and they just
thought you know you want a good path
with them and
yeah it's all about the security but i
am not about security
like you only get one life so why not
have fun with it and it is a big i mean
if you were my daughter i mean even as
your mentor i was a little bit worried
when you told me you'd quit your job
and if you were my daughter i think i
can completely understand you're
laughing at the thought but i can
completely understand why a father or a
mother would be like what are you doing
you you've got this great career you're
being paid a nice salary you're 19.
you've got the rest of your life to do
entrepreneurial stuff but just get
yourself get your degree get your you
know
build work your way up in your career so
i can't understand why they were a
little bit apprehensive and shout out to
you dad he was a guarantor to you as
well so he obviously does support you
very much as a person but the move to
just
quick was was a bold one yeah it was a
bold one but i mean i've always had a
lot of self-belief i knew i could do it
and i don't like that stigma of well you
must finish the degree or you must wait
two years yeah i left it all oh you you
just left oh i was just oh where's the
degree gonna get me it's just a piece of
paper
ouch ouch
wow i didn't know that so you were
studying what um financial investments
like stocks and shares and um and you
just left you just left it yeah and
joined the academy
that is crazy and
did you use part of your student loan to
join the academy i wasn't paying for the
degree the company paid for the degree
right so i was i was living a
a perfect life you know i was getting
paid to do a degree at 18 years old i
was doing full-time job for one of the
biggest investment banks in the whole
world
i
only the top 1 actually got into the job
um so that in itself was a big
accomplishment for me
uh so yeah a lot of people were very
questioning of my decisions but i just
think with degrees nowadays like
unless you need it
what's the point i'd rather start
property now and be successful
now than wait two years and look back
and regret it right and another thing is
as well and this is a very personal
decision and what you took was personal
but if you finish una and then you're in
a job get married have a couple kids
suddenly if you're in a job it's much
harder there's never a right time to
quit no and what i said at the time was
i have no responsibility i don't have a
mortgage i don't have children
i don't have loads of bills to pay
if i'm going to take a risk
the best time to take a risk is now and
my old team my boss
he actually tried to convince me to say
and we got him really well but he even
said to me he said look if all fails
give me a call right and he would have
sorted me out so i knew that even if the
worst happened which i didn't even think
of it i always was gonna be fine i'm
young i can afford to take a risk now
it's better doing it now than when i'm
30 years old with all their
responsibilities right you're a smart 20
year old you're a smart 20 year old so
and after that first property
you went and got more i mean this
property is another one yes so where's
this this is in winchester and how much
profit roughly is this is this property
uh generating so on average about 2 000
pounds a month and on a good month about
three thousand pounds a month
just on one property just on one rent
rent that is ridiculous i can't say how
proud i am of what you've done uh and i
know you've got a bunch of other
properties as well in the pipeline
you've got agents that are
you know very happy to give you deals
but just off of those two
that's more money than you were making
on your secure job yeah way more and
also i don't have to work 12 hours a day
being bored to get it right which is the
best thing like i love painting and
decorating and like
choosing interior design and stuff which
is why i love service accommodation
so it's much more fun i can do on my
laptop while i'm watching friends like
that's the crazy thing is that's my job
like i said to my sister the other day
she went where are you going i was like
oh i've got to go to ikea that's part of
my job now. she went no i went it
actually is in my job description
probably is go to ikea to get furniture
right which is crazy and and and and
you know you kind of it's a different
way of life isn't it your your work just
becomes a way of life as opposed to nine
to five or nine to six yeah exactly like
it's a lot more fluid but i enjoy it i
can choose my hours which means that i
can see friends and family around all of
that and in between so yeah it's great
what makes you so successful
um
just the attitude
like
just don't moan don't make excuses
get networking even if you feel a bit
awkward
yeah like i do remember i did feel a bit
nervous walking into that service
accommodation event because i didn't
know anyone and i didn't have anything
um but then as soon as i was there i
knew that it was the right decision i
think you're gonna challenge
and inspire a lot of people because the
fact that you've been able to do it so
young and just not just do it but boss
it and breeze it just so quickly on on
your first day of being on training you
went and got a deal yeah that's
incredible and i know a lot of people
there were doing the same thing right
yeah because i'm not a bad trainer no
and i'll
make people do stuff yeah but you know
i'm really impressed and
your results at your age are not typical
i mean
even the deals that you've got like two
to three grand off of one deal
how are you getting so much profit from
this from this property i mean i always
knew that winchester was a very like
affluent area very popular the nightly
prices are crazy
um and the properties around here are
gorgeous so i knew
i had got a lot of rejection from
certain agents but i just knew
winchester is the area i need to carry
on and this particular property the
agent said sorry we're not prepared to
do it the landlord's up for it but we
can't do it on rent to rent and rather
than you saying oh i got a rejection
what did you do
oh i phoned the landlord how did you get
the landlord's details the essay agents
were lovely and they are a branch in
winchester and they actually said if it
were our way we would do it we
understand company let's we think
they're great but it was just higher it
was above them right um said that the
legal team couldn't do it and the stage
was really nice and gave me all the
landlords details and said he'll be in
contact shortly so yeah i am still very
grateful for them
um
and yeah and then the landlord called me
um i spoke to him we got on so well he's
got loads of other properties in london
and around he's a very wealthy lawyer in
dubai so he's got a lot of property in
england and he said if this one goes
well he'd love to show me his other ones
so yeah you know from one contact i've
got potential and the thing is as well
you pay the landlord how much do you pay
for this house
1550. that is not a lot not no not for
winchester and this is the most central
property i've ever found it's got all
the gorgeous old features of the massive
ceilings the windows are incredible
and the door like they are features and
when it comes to service accommodation
it's all about what can you offer that's
unique right you know no one wants to
come from their boring gray beige home
to another boring beige grey home yeah
but what you did so well with this
landlord was you took a property from a
motivated landlord because he was living
in dubai it was a state yes and you've
done it up and it was literally it was
full of junk so the lamp from the llamas
perspective he's happy for you to clean
it all up as part of the part of the
deal how much money did you spend
getting this rent around because you've
had to refurb it paint it furnish it
with this beautiful sofa and everything
and beds upstairs
how much does it cost so for the
decorating i only spent about
500 pounds i did pay uh two months rent
up front um just to offer more security
to the landlord and a deposit as well i
know a lot of people say to negotiate a
deposit but
you know a lot of people they want a
deposit they don't know you so sometimes
you just have to did you get a guarantor
for this property no he didn't because
remember when you said to me you were
like my dad doesn't want to be a
guarantor a second time and what did i
say to you
said try and negotiate it without or
find another one maybe i didn't say it
to you but you know what i thought what
i'd i'll have to look back at the
history i thought if you can't get going
talk i'll be a guarantor
uh um can i tell you that i think you
said worst concert absolutely no
literally i can't remember what i said
to you on facebook i might even have to
have a look now yeah but i was like i
said to you come on the academy call
oh yeah yeah pitch pitch that you need a
guarantor try and do what you can do and
if you can't come back to me yeah they
don't say it to you but in my head i
knew if you can't get a guarantor i'll
be a guarantor exactly i didn't want to
lose prophecy and had it still been with
the agent i would have needed a
guarantor and i did actually approach
someone and they told me that they would
be my ground tub i'd have to give them
50 of the profit yep you told me that
hey here we go and you said i'm i will
get going tour but someone wants to put
the profit which is ridiculous yeah and
i said send me the figures i'll take a
look then let's pitch it tonight to the
mastermind
i'm confident someone buy i'll help you
come up with a proposition
um okay i didn't actually tell you but i
i was thinking if you can't i'll be a
guarantor oh thank you because i saw how
hard you were working yeah and what you
were doing and some people would go oh
her dad was a guy on tour it's easy for
some it's like no you joined the academy
i was gonna say you know the right
people like bless like even people like
kim was like oh i would you know i would
and knowing people like that is just
amazing they would do what they go on
tour yeah
wow yeah you know and
a few months ago i didn't know them and
now they're willing to put their name on
a legal document for me
is amazing so yeah networking attending
the weekly calls makes a huge difference
putting yourself around serious people
another thing we talked about as well
you said a lot of people come to you
saying can you help me can you just
and it's like well
not really not unless you help yourself
yeah like if you've done the training
and then
you know want my advice or want to meet
then of course i'd love to network with
people
but if you're not willing to invest in
yourself why should i waste my time
because you don't know anything and
people that say they do off
you know two youtube videos you don't
yeah like it's can you run a business in
service accommodation we can all furnish
a house
but then what do you do right
you need to know how to systemize it
yeah you need to know how to how to put
cleaners in place not just cleaners but
how to make sure that they can manage
the the booking system yeah you need to
be able to set up channel managers or
are you going to manage yourself how do
you avoid double bookings how do you
deal with the whole review thing in
place
the linen exactly and you have it
yourself but you need to know how to put
systems in place so that it gets done
and that's what a lot of landlords that
often see i've seen this so many times
landlords and if maybe if your
landlord's watching this now this should
be good for them to hear because
landlords they're like oh my gosh you're
paying me just 1500 but you're making
three grand i'll do that yeah and then
when the contract ends how long is this
contract three years three years they
take it back they try and do it
themselves and they can't yeah they just
can't because they think it's about
putting it on airbnb and waiting for the
bookings to come in yeah but it's way
more to than that yeah there's so much
more to it and that's why you need the
training right because there are tiny
little things that you would never think
you have to worry about and then they
come up and you do yeah yeah so yeah
like even like bing collections right
people don't think of that
but you need to because again you can't
ask a guest to put your bin bags out
you know someone's got to be responsible
for it and it's about systemizing it uh
having a welcome pack when they arrive
so they know where things are the wi-fi
password and just making sure
everything's top-notch because if you
try and do service accommodation but you
mess up and do it wrong you're gonna get
bad reviews yeah then you're not gonna
get bookings as soon as you get bad
reviews you can call it a night because
they are everything
and it can be as simple as one little
thing that went wrong and you have to be
able to either remedy the situation
quick or you know to ensure that you can
get a good review because that is
everything yeah what do people say now
you're financially free and you're 20.
what do your friends and family think
um now they're very supportive although
my dad and mom do still tell me to be
careful
they're still yeah oh they're oh they
still my dad is the most risk adverse
person you will ever meet because
normally it's be careful and then it's
well we'll see we'll see and then it's
money isn't everything you know
yeah no i mean
i think if i bought him a nice fishing
boat then he'd stop telling me to be
careful we'll maybe make that happen one
day one day one day yeah so i mean but
it's great they must be shocked that
you're now
literally getting more money and you
don't have to go to work
they're not shocked at all
um i was always quite a confident kid
and i always all my aspiring jobs was
always you know
ceo director it was always something
where i was in control of my
life so they weren't shocked at all the
only thing that shocked them was when i
left my job so quick because they didn't
know how unhappy i was because i don't
really tend to tell people how i feel
i'm very
closed off
um
and had they have known how i'd felt for
months i think they would have been
different what how did you feel
or phone about your job yeah like
depressed like you just wake up and do
the same routine and you look forward to
the weekend the weekend comes it goes
really quick and then you just dread
the next working week and it was just a
vicious cycle all the time and lockdown
made it worse because i couldn't even
look forward to my weekends
how do you feel now compared to them
amazing i live in the present i'm not
always just
waiting and waiting
for something to happen like i enjoy
every day i love what i do
and i'm really really happy and even if
i'm working a 12-hour day it's doing
something that i love and it's actually
going to benefit me right
what does an average because i know
sometimes you have to work hard in this
business yeah i know also you you often
now you take a lot of nice days off what
does an average day look like for darcy
so
if i've got a like service accommodation
to do then i would normally
get up and
get showered and ready and then come
straight here
book a tip slot probably be taking
something to the tip
and then just keep renovating it
probably eat dinner out of a takeaway
box
[Laughter]
love a good takeaway
and then yeah just keep going and then
go home and sleep
if i'm not you know renovating a house
then i'd wake up go to the gym come back
get ready maybe go for a forest walk
have some nice lunch then make my asian
calls sift through my emails see if
there's any little bits and bobs i need
to order and then it's a pretty chilled
evening you know i have i cook a nice
dinner sit with my family and just chill
sounds great yeah it's a nice life is it
a big contrast now and last year yeah
massively like it's just it's weird how
like if i want to have a lion oh i can
yeah you know i haven't got to get up
for anyone normally
how does your partner ben think about
everything oh he loves it he gets
jealous when he has to get up and go to
work
and i'm here yeah what have been some of
the tough times because you do have a
thing of making everything look so easy
and seamless you know what's been some
of the tough days through the last six
twelve months of getting becoming
financially free i think the toughest
days for me was when i was getting
viewings and the agent was really nice
and it all seemed to go ahead and then
it didn't yeah i'll never forget where
i'm before i got the portsmouth one i
actually secured one in winchester my
dream place
and it was a two-bedroom apartment
gorgeous like i fell in love i know they
say i don't buy with emotions but this
place like i was
um
and because i was inexperienced
the landlord asked to see my business
accounts but obviously i didn't have
anything in there because i was brand
new and instead of saying oh it's a new
company i can give you references
instead i just transferred some money
over and sent the screenshot like they
asked i should never have done that
i did and then i lost that deal and i
was
like devastated i was so
angry and distraught and then it took me
a good few weeks before i came and of
course to find another one so the
hardest times is when you've been
calling agents for weeks you get the
viewings and nothing happens and you
just think like when am i gonna catch a
break right but all the no's are worth
the one yes that's right i mean
technically you know if you're this deal
is basically just to steal alone it's
financial freedom yeah so you don't need
to get a lot of yeses and that's the
thing if you look at any sports um you
know if you watch sport and you'll see
them keep shoot miss shoot miss shoot
miss shoot miss and then they'll get a
goal and then they win the game and yeah
it's it's easy to get disheartened by
the times you missed yeah but actually
you shouldn't be counting the times you
miss you should be just saying well i
only did it once twice and yeah be
life-changing and i think for me like
sometimes it was really hard seeing some
of your success streams i always like
watch them and like say sometimes they
make it seem so easy like oh i own 10k a
month now in three months and you think
what i've been working so hard i'm not
even
close to that and sometimes that would
get to me but then i would have calls
with like your weekly call or with a
mentor and they would have to remind me
you know take it at your own pace right
like your story is very different to
anyone else's yeah and you will get
there and that's the point i realized i
need to stop comparing myself
because i used to do that and it would
just make me feel bad about myself if i
wasn't there yeah that's interesting
because there might be some people
watching this even now that see you and
there'll be some people that are really
inspired but there'll be some people
that think ah [ __ ] you know yeah why am
i not there and they'll maybe try and
either they'll feel shitty about it and
beat themself up or they'll try to pull
you down yeah and say oh it's just
because i bet her dad gave a load of
money you know um but you were certainly
weren't born with a silver spoon in your
mouth no i come from normal family i
mean in the childhood it got to the
point where you know it was just beans
and bread
really yeah i'm not from a wealthy
background at all my dad started his
business from nothing and they were
trying to raise a family and raise a
house and so you know you'd go
shopping to like audi and you'd only be
able to buy like
uh beans or like if you're a kid you
could only get one half meal between my
sister just because it cost
so i definitely didn't grow up in that
lifestyle at all right so you've seen
what it's like to not have a lot and
then you've had a you've then you've
seen security and been in the case where
you've got a job which is like a rat
race yeah and and now finally freedom
financial freedom yeah i think when you
see like your parents work so so hard
but you don't see the rewards it
definitely makes you think
um like i don't i don't want to be like
that and you know i think that
definitely pushed me so i know people go
money isn't everything but actually it
is a lot of it it is
like it allows you just to have freedom
live comfortably i i always said like i
would never want to spend my life
stressing about money
like there's so much more things i could
be putting my energy into than worrying
about the food bill about you know like
when you're a kid and you play sports
that cost your parents money you don't
realize at the time but they're working
extra hard just to keep you in a sport
so it's stuff like that i just wouldn't
ever want to have to worry yeah
do you ever pinch yourself when you look
at what you've done
property wise
no i haven't yet it hasn't settled in
i i think because i have such massive
goals yeah that like i have to remind
myself to celebrate the smaller wins
right and to other people it's a big win
but to me i'm like
i want to be in the millions so you know
wow
so you feel like you're just warming up
yeah this is just the taster session
this year when we sat down you were like
so is this actually winners on wednesday
i could yeah i still can't believe this
is winners on a wednesday because like i
said to my boyfriend ben like
i used to watch them and i said like i'm
gonna be on that but i didn't expect it
to happen this fast yeah so it's really
weird how long have you been watching my
youtube videos
i'd say a good year now yeah so yeah and
and what's the experience been like on
the academy working with me or what's it
been like it's been amazing i really
didn't expect you to be as hands-on or
friendly
not like friendly but like you have so
many students yeah and so like when
you're you actually i remember the first
time you texted me on facebook i was
like what
i like showed my family like he texts me
of all his students yeah um so that
really surprised me but obviously in a
good way like you and your team like
ricky and i said that all actually just
so friendly
and like meeting people on the academy
and stuff they're just incredible as
well like you know i never thought that
i would just be able to
text people and ask for their advice and
yeah it's great have you made a lot of
good friends yeah
yeah always go to your events now with
george which is great yeah he's a friend
that i met through your he's also a
young guy on the academy then you've got
people like kim you've been friends with
who's a different generation yeah
killing it in property as well i know
she's like a property mum to everyone
though isn't she like she's so mothering
what would your advice be to somebody
watching this that's thinking i want to
do the same thing i'm tired of my job
i'm tired of anyone what would be your
best advice
just take the risk and take the action
and don't expect results overnight like
you have to actually put in work yeah it
doesn't just come and there will be a
lot of no's on the phone a lot of
awkwardness a lot of like disappointment
but once you get that one yes you will
forget all those horrible phone calls
that you had yeah exactly that's great
well i'm so proud of you darcy and
i'm so pleased to see you doing really
well
and most importantly is not just what
you how much money you're making and all
that but it's how your life has changed
yeah it's just it's it for me it's
really fulfilling as a trainer to see
somebody like you said you were feeling
depressed and you're in a job that you
didn't enjoy
quit that out with the old out of the
old in with the news yeah to see what
you're doing to just come around meet
your partner baron um you know i'm
really really proud of you and also as
well massive shout out to your family
and parents that just i know they were a
bit skeptical and they were like well
but still for supporting you yeah and um
i know they didn't give you any money
but just sort of standing with you in it
um you know shout out to them if they're
listening and massive congratulations
thank you
well done
guys i hope you are feeling inspired
this is darcy i'll leave a link to her
instagram and stuff in the description
so connect with darcy also if you'd like
to come on the property investors crash
course then come and join for some free
training what's the free training like
by the way amazing you learn so much you
don't have to just do the advanced
training if you want to get like
one-on-one mentoring and support then
yes there are some options but a lot of
the training is free so you can come on
down i'll leave a link in the
description check it out also don't
forget to subscribe to the channel hit
like and if you've got questions for
darcy why don't you hit it in the
comment box i'm sure she'll i'm sure
she'll respond some of the questions in
the comment box i certainly will be so
comment below on the video and we'll see
you next time peace